all right good morning everyone we need
to get a little audience feedback here
so we need somebody to give us a word to
start out an exercise so whatever comes
to the top of your mind just shout out a
word we're going to black is always
funny when it bounces all right thank
you yes now those of you who are
familiar with the world of improv
probably recognize that exercise for
those of you who aren't the game we just
played is called prophecy and it
involves getting a suggestion from the
audience a word and then each member of
the team builds on that word until you
build some sort of wise saying and what
we'd like to do today is expand your
definition of the world of improv and
show you how improv can actually apply
in your communications strategies so
we're gonna pull some tips from this
book improv wisdom by Patricia Madson
and our team Jen Donna Simone and I Dave
will walk you through six different
strategies or what Patricia calls
mantras from the improv world that you
can use in everyday communication now
when you think of improv you probably
think of these three things right don't
prepare just show up and say yes now
don't prepare it's pretty obvious right
I mean improv is all about rolling with
the punches going off the cuff and just
seeing what happens but there's a deeper
meaning here for communication where it
really involves being in
moment and really paying attention to
what's happening now not thinking about
what's coming next for just show up it's
also again a little obvious but whenever
you're having some sort of communication
whether it be delivering a presentation
at the front of G 101 or having a
difficult conversation with your boss
you need to physically be present to
start that exercise and finally say yes
it's important to note here that this is
yes and often we hear people say no but
it's really in the form of yes boss yes
but is really a blocking exercise but a
vault that allows you to control the
situation yes and really allows you to
be more supportive and open so we would
encourage you as you communicate more
with others to show that support and
that willingness to engage by using the
phrase yes yes and be averaged thanks
Dave by a show of hands how many people
here consider themselves to be
perfectionist yeah that's what I thought
me too giving presentations can be in
high-stakes situation we want it to be
just right often our reputation our
credibility even potentially our career
advancement could all be on the line and
what ends up happening is that we put
this pressure on ourselves to be perfect
to do it and what ends up happening is
that it juice us we end up psyching
ourselves out it's a paradox right the
moment when you've worked your hardest
and you've put in the most effort the
results are disappointing
Patricia Madison in improv wisdom
suggests a better approach be average
take the pressure off don't walk into a
presentation thinking I've got
this is gonna be the best or I have to
be creative
instead dare to be dull be nothing
special and cultivate an ordinary mind
it's ironic right but here are the two
steps you need to take in order to
embrace this philosophy number one give
up on being perfect you're going to make
mistakes so just accept it number two
often when we're trying to be creative
we think that we have to be outside the
box really being inside the box it's
just as useful sometimes the best
solutions are the ones that are right in
front of us so the next time you're
giving a presentation I want you to
forget about being perfect
and I want you to embrace being average
yes and be pay attention paying
attention is important because your
presentation is about the audience
it's about your conversation with that
and when I think of phrase pay attention
comes to mind as total listening
listening not only with your ears with
your eyes too and this is what we do
every day because why is what we
experience in this world greatly depends
on what we decide to focus on in the
moment and this includes when you
present you when you're on stage so to
create that bond with the audience to
make that conversation go you have to be
a detective that is look at okay who's
holding out contact with
who's smiling thank you who maybe
writing their notes right now who's
looking at their computer and what is
the general move the audience because
just like I believe your team of taka
you gave different tips for reach out to
the audience something and you could
gauge that protein s based on what the
audience's feedback is yes you're doing
all the talking but your eyes is
communicating with you too so what I
want you to do is to pay attention by
totally listening to the audience with
your ears and your eyes and be a
detective because you can make a much
more powerful presentation and your
audience could walk away remembering
what you said if you create that
dialogue and just pay attention yes and
face the facts thank you
another key mantra in improv is that a
little tidbit that the player before you
throws into a stage simply now becomes
reality so for example if I are just
help Simone that this is a dog Simone
would have to simply accept that this is
indeed a dog this very simple kind of
improv mantra can also apply to
ourselves when we give speeches as much
as JD and Burke tried over the course of
this quarter it may simply be that
sometimes I forgot to take a power pose
or sometimes as much as I may have
practiced I end up doing a little bit of
a talk but the fact of the matter is we
have to embrace the wobble because
scientifically quite literally our
muscles only get stronger if we embrace
that struggle another way of applying
face the facts is in our professional
lives because if there's one thing that
we can count on the facts that may come
our way can be an unexpected or expected
it can be positive or negative
but they are facts they are in fact our
reality and the best way to face those
facts is instead of trying to contort or
avoid them is to look at it directly in
the face and then move forward so
whether it be you find yourself on the
stage of your next improv troupe or
perhaps it's simply that next Thursday
you'll be given grace at Thanksgiving
dinner the next time you give a speech
or next time you make a decision
remember to face the facts yes and
improv is wise so today we've taken you
through six different mantras six
different ideas that you can take from
the world of improv and apply to your
communications and before we let you go
we want to make sure that we don't leave
you with the wrong impression so coming
into today if I would have asked you
what improv is all about the first thing
a lot of you probably would have gone to
is being funny it's about comedy well
yes and it's about more than just that
so we hope today that we have expanded
your definition of what improv is and
shown you how you can apply that in
other situations the other thing is we
don't mean to suggest that you should
never prepare there's a fair amount of
preparation that went into this
presentation we would hope that if you
have to have surgery at some point that
your surgeon is well prepared for that
but we do believe that there are
elements of improv that will allow you
to roll with the punches and just be
more effective on a day to day basis in
communicating so remember to be average
to face the facts and to pay attention
so that you can show
you